يتدربون اثنتي عشره ساعه في اليوم لسته
ايام في الاسبوع يصارعون عدوهم الاول
الوقت يطوعون ثلاثه اشهر من التدريب
الالزامي في خمسه او ثمانيه اسابيع كحد
اقصى ويعيدون بناء جيش قادرا على استعمال
الات الحرب الحديثه فعشرون بالمئه فقط من
الجيش الاوكراني قادر على التعامل مع
الدبابات الحربيه في ساعات الصباح الاولى
يبدا الجنود الاوكران التدريب في مركز سان
جورجو العسكري في زيرا جوزا شرقيه اسبانيا
حوالي 55 جنديا يتدربون على قطع تحاكي
العمل على الدبابات الحقيقيه قبل خروجهم
الى معسكرات التدريب تتطلب دبابه ليو بارد
الواحده طاقم من يتكون من اربعه جنود
لتشغيلها بالمقابل فهي تقدم مميزات عده
تجعل قرار ارسال مئات الجنود الاوكران
للتدريب في خضم الحرب قرارا مهما ويعد
مدفع دبابات ليو بورد اثنان من اهم
الميزات الموجوده فيها اذ يمتلك قدره ثبات
عاليه على الاراضي غير المستويه بسرعه 70
كم مدعوم بنظام تحكم رقمي ميزه تفتقر لها
الدبابات الاوكرانيه التي تعود لعهد
الاتحاد السوفيتي كما ان مقدمه الدبابه
مدعومه بصفائح مضاده للالغام ميزه اخرى
امام الالغام الروسيه الذكيه التي تقفز من
مكانها لاقتناص الدبابات الاوكرانيه
يظل تحدي الاكبر هو امكانيه توظيف
التدريبات المكثفه التي تلقاها الجنود في
ميدان المعارك المشتعله الذي سيكون الحسم
في رهان الغربي على هذه الدبابات كرم
حناوي العربيه